hello everyone and welcome to one of the
finest games we've seen in a while it's
actually a game from the 2016 world
rapid
championship that took place in qatar
doha you know the one won by
uh the great vasiliy vanchuk uh and it's
a game between tamura jabo and alexander
boternick
and it features uh well such such a
brilliant move that uh
the move alone will make you enjoy this
game immensely so without further ado
let's check it out as there is uh a lot
to cover it's a very short game but
still
it features a lot of very cool lines so
uh rajab opens with
knight to f3 he opts for the retti
opening we have d6 and now
d4 we have knight to f6 and both players
now prepare to fianchetto their uh king
side bishop so g3 we have g6
uh bishop to g2 bishop to g7 and b3
rajab also now prepares the fiance uh
the the dark square bishop as well
and black says that's perfectly fine
this is after all still
uh all standard theory so here uh bishop
back to beat bishop to b2
and now nowadays um maybe knight b to d7
or e5 would be
uh the the go-to moves but in those days
bishop to f5 was also
a very much a playable move so here
rajab continues uh grabbing more space
in the center
we have c4 and now queen to c8 and with
this move black makes his plans um
uh known he wants to play bishop to h3
and he wants to eliminate
white's light square bishop and then
weaken white's king side so here we have
h3
rajab of prevents that and now c5
striking in the center and here you have
to be careful
a little bit your bishop here is
undefended if the position opens up
you might you might lose it so here
knight to c3
again just continuing development this
pawn is very nicely defended by the
queen and by the knight so it's not a
problem
knight to c6 uh continuing development
and adding more pressure to the center
and now we have rook to c1 and it is as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game now or as this is a game from 2016
uh this position has never been reached
again and
the reason i haven't covered any games
from this tournament is because
uh i was uh pretty much just starting
out in 2016
with with the channel and um yeah this
this was just happening but i was
following the tournament online
so here bishop to h6 black decides to
get uh
to make a white get rid of this rook
from c1 but
this is already where things get very
interesting here uh rajab of push is d5
and now we have this um weird position
where
a white is offering a rook but we often
know when black goes for this uh
setup where he wants to have a nice
bishop fiance on g7
uh if the bishop is eliminated then you
will have a dark square weaknesses
because all of your pawns are now on
light squares and as
white has a very strong dark square
bishop this could be a problem
so uh just the five better job of going
after the knight here
and you don't have to go after the rook
but let's say you go knights to e5
and now knight to h4 what do you play
here you still kind of have to go after
the rook there's
um i mean there's not all that much you
can do here if you try something like
g5 to try and force white to capture
here
white can even play queen d2 and now you
cannot capture because the bishop is
hanging and it's a really really crazy
position
and if you don't have compensation for
weakening your king's position like this
you don't really want to do it
so instead after d5 after all this is a
rapid game black decides okay
what's the worst that can happen he
plays bishop captures on c1
and rajabo grabs it with the queen and
now the queen
gains access to the h6 square so here we
have knight to d4
now uh offering to trade on more
material black is now up material and he
wants to trade down and of course he
doesn't mind captures captures
as this also trades uh down material
even further so here
uh rajab of continues pushing on the
king's side he plays
g4 now forces this bishop to move back
and you don't have a very good square
other than uh d7 so this is what he goes
for we have bishop to d7 bishop to c2
also may be playable but i mean it's
such a such a weird move to play
um and and also you know the knight can
be captured then captures attacks this
night it's it's a very complicated line
but
okay it's a rapid game you don't want to
calculate too much so bishop back to d7
and now comes queen to h6 and already
this is very unpleasant the knight is
probably coming to g5 and then this
knight is stuck here forever you have to
guard this uh
h7 pawn h4 h5 is always an idea just
opening up the h5 for the rook
so black needs to find a reasonable way
to defend and what other beta a
way to do it then to remove one of the
active attackers so knight captures an
f3
bishop captures in the now knights the
e8 it's not the knight discovering the
g7 square and for the moment black
doesn't have to worry about the g7
square
and here tamer decides that he's going
to go for knight to e4 now he wants to
bring the other knights to g5
uh but i will show it as it's a it's a
very forcing line h4
is also very much playable but like i
said it's a rapid game you can't spend
all that much time
calculating the point is that you can
give up the g for pawn and then just
play h5 and you're
you're you're just completely winning if
g captures you're just gonna play bishop
captures
and after queen captures you're going to
eliminate this spawn threatening
rogue g5 and that's a game over whatever
you play if if queen g1 checked you you
just move the king
it's not a problem next move rook g5
wins the game there there's no move
black in play
but okay knights the e4 was played in
the game also seems to be
very nice as the knight is coming to g5
but here black has this very stubborn
defense of f6 and now
uh white again needs to find a way to go
about to this position
and now only now timur goes for h4 and
h5
uh we have bishop captures on g4 the
only uh
playable move by black and now h5
so preparing to open up the h file for
the rook we have g
captures on h5 and now comes knight to
g5 this is what you have to resort to as
uh black now has f6 played so uh you
don't have checkmate here as the knight
is covering that so it doesn't matter if
the the pawn captures but uh you don't
really have a better move or rather
there is one and again i will show it
because
i know you guys enjoy seeing it here it
seems like uh
you're completely lost queen captures on
h7 is coming and the only good defense
is rook to f7
uh the reason why rook to f7 is good is
because
uh well this cannot be calculated in a
rapid game the point is after knight
captures you have to play queen to f5
and if you find queen to f5
uh then everything falls into place
because the knight has no squares the
knight will be recaptured
and even if you go for something like
captures and captures again you don't
have to worry about the h file being
open as the h7 pawn is defended by the
queen
and now even if rook to h5 there's this
queen to b1 check and if bishop blocks
then just king captures an f7
and you are perfectly fine here the
queen still defends this pawn this queen
must guard the bishop here and you don't
have pretty
really anything better than just a trade
queens captures captures and captures
and after this we have this endgame
where the material is uh
completely even so this is what uh
might be possible if black finds the
absolute best uh maneuver but that is
very rarely the case in actual game so
here f captures and g5 is played
and now comes queen captures on g5 with
check you don't really have any options
if you block with the knight then this
is just checkmate
so the only move is king to f7 and now
there is only
one move uh that uh wins the game for
rajabov so feel free to pause the video
and try to find
this elusive idea from the position in
the thumbnail
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
parting with your queen and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
queen
captures an h5 this beautiful queen
sacrifice is the only move that wins the
game
and i know what you're saying uh you're
probably saying surely
something like rook captures on h5 wins
uh just as well i mean
what can what can black do the problem
is black has this annoying again queen
to f5 move and this
saves him the game now you're again
guarding the h7 square
you're offering a queen trade and
there's not much more you can do if
bishop captures on g4 now you again have
this queen to b1
check and it's not a problem bishop c1
knight to f6 defends everything attacks
the rook defends this rook to g8 is
coming
and black is even better here so the uh
fact of the matter is that a queen
captures an h5 with
check is the only winning idea here
point is uh you do not have king to g8
then queen captures on h7 is just
checkmate now the h file has
opened up as the queen eliminated the h
pawn so here
your only move possible is bishop
captures an h5 but now comes
white's decisive attack bishop captures
an h5 with
check king to g8 and now rook to g1
again with check you have to block this
knight to g7
and now uh white is going uh to force
black into some windmill action so uh
rook captures with czech king to h8
and now this is called the windmill uh
because the bishop is ready to deliver
check and wherever the rook moves a
check will be delivered so what can you
play here uh if
um if this pawn wasn't here you you just
play something like route to g6 you
deliver check and that would be it for
example rook f6 bishop captures this
would be checkmate
but since the e7 pawn is here first
we're going to eliminate this pawn with
check so rook captures with check and
now what do you play here if king g8 now
now like we've said
the pawn has been eliminated and now we
just deliver checkmate rook g7 check
king h8
and now rook anywhere along the the g
file even rook g1 is enough because
after the rook blocks this will be
checkmate all of these squares are
covered
so after rook captures on e7 black tried
rook to f6
this vacates the f8 square for the black
king so here
bishop captures an f6 with check king to
g8 and now again
rook the g7 with check so if you go to
h8 then just moving the rook is
checkmate
so king to f8 and now comes rook
captures an h7
and here rajab says i control these
three squares
with my bishop pair as you can see it is
the most definitely fully operational
uh and here black doesn't have a move
whatever you play next move is
rook to h8 checkmate okay you could
prolong maybe the game with some silly
moves like queen to g4
but on this channel we do not discuss
such moves so here
queen to f5 was played uh why black had
to play something
and of course in the next move uh java
played rook to h8 and
this is now checkmate i took 29 moves
and like i said in modern chess
uh this can very well be considered a
miniature and since it features such a
beautiful queen sacrifice
uh it's uh you know definitely a game
that should be
shown as uh you know those are the games
that we enjoyed the most
so uh if you guys want we can check this
out once more in slow motion so there we
have it queen capture sun h5 happened
at this moment on move 21 there you go
queen captures uh with check and then
everything else followed
uh checkmate was was delivered as
promised
so after rook 8 uh botanic of course uh
lost the game
and a very nice victory uh for temura
java in this
beautiful game that was played in the
2016 a world rapid
championship that was won by vasily evan
chuck
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it uh
of course uh if you have any other
suggestions such as this one this also
comes as a suggestion from a subscriber
do use hashtag suggestion or just email
me and then we we can cover
uh the games as nice as this one uh so
yeah
i would like to thank uh jack varadian
blast off lunar c abrati mukherjee and
brandon luc
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day